the Joe Rogan experience we're bananas
it's crazy and then you know what it is
though here's the the real victims of
ending the drug war would be all those
prisons that would no longer be full of
young black men you say this but what if
your business is run prisons right what
if your business is prison guards I mean
that's not someone someone think of the
prison the prison industrial complex
yeah prison guards lobby against drug
legalization they do it because they
want to stay in office they want to keep
their jobs and how many lives has to be
ruined in the process fucking crazy no
it's a vampire system it's a horrible
vampire system and it's a system that's
brought out of its it's based on these
reverberations or these vibrations from
the past it's all like this scramble
when a people retarded when they came
over on boats and this is just how they
did things they demand that Clank throw
in a jail you know fucking scoundrel you
were smoking marijuana or whatever the
rule that you broke is that they realize
that they can do it so they do do it and
they throw you in some fucking cage in
2014 the fact that's still going on and
that people are actually profiting from
it this is these are more things that
the internet has a huge fuckin problem
with because the Internet is guys like
you as young fellas that are very smart
and unconventional and seeing the system
and being like you know what I don't buy
it I think there's a shit that people I
knew growing up that were adults I knew
there were fucking idiots and then
getting made bad choices and now I'm
looking at the the repercussions of this
everywhere I'm looking at it I'm saying
no dudes is dumb this is so this is one
of the things especially talking to
college students that I love bringing up
which is that and I'm the first to admit
it like I have no fucking clue what I'm
doing
99% of the time especially when I got
started I still don't know and I've come
to realize like and I've got I've got
lucky enough to meet some pretty like
successful impressive people but like
you think on the surface we're all just
hacking it like we're all just for your
expertise experience those things I'll
help but like every one of us is a
fallible human all the conventions and
rules and status quo we know were
created by other fallible humans yeah
and there's no reason not to look at
that and go huh
does it have to be that way or why is it
that way and if the reason why is little
it's the way it is well that's a
terrible reason you know and and when
you see the world as being that hackable
so to speak like you start to realize
all right well let's just let's actually
question stuff and and for you know I
remember I was a freshman at UVA when
9/11 happened for this generation of
Millennials coming up we we moat nearly
all of us one of our first really vivid
memories of the world was 9/11 this
awful tragedy and then we get into these
two wars and then think of all the
authority figures we've had in our life
since that moment they've all at one
point uh they're either mislead us this
sort of deceived us
you've got the financial crisis you've
got the housing bubble all these
conventions Oh trust us we know we're
doing this is the thing the American
Dream is buying a home go to college
take on that student loan debt don't
worry there's a job waiting for you
every single all these conventions from
from all these people in power have not
held up and so I think in particular
Milanoo Millennials look at that very
skeptically because we're like alright
you know it so the conventional stuff
didn't work out for anything like we
have no choice but to realize you know
what we're all just hacking it so let's
let's really let's dive into the passion
let's let's figure out a better way to
do something not settle for it's the way
to always been I think you're completely
right and I think first of all I'm
slightly annoyed by this new statement
and I'm first to absorb Millennials I
know it's a terrible phrase I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm not buying we can rebrand
this I think we should I really believe
this is I think there's a divisive
Nisour there's a separation that comes
when you start labeling people by like
what era they were born in fair enough
it's a it's a state of mind more than
anything else yeah I think so but I
think it's horseshit fuck up it's just
humans like this is this idea of putting
things in a labeled generalization the
human race is evolving watch father
knows best and then watch Game of
Thrones okay different now we don't have
to come up with names for the
generations and your generation why and
there was fuckin Jamie from the Laugh
Factory tried to tell my friend Todd
Parker Todd Parker's a stand-up comic
that I started out with Jamie was like
buddy you have to be Generation X guy
this is what you do you go on stage and
everything my generation Generation X
think that's going to be your hook and I
remember him trying to explain it to
change when I'm in the background going
what he told Tony to do what he told you
you must always wear cowboy hat just
look like Woody from Toy Story is you
needed a hat